hello and welcome to zo GM duck have a
man it's all the funny name did someone
wants explain to me who that is I don't
remember dark half a man ok ty can just
do this stay Kings Indian style
isn't that this position where you for
as possible efore
we were the Knights have no squares I
thought isn't that the position i
stumbled into this one myself in a game
some years ago and I let's go for it I
don't see why it shouldn't work if he
takes with either night I'm going f5 and
it should win a piece and the night is
hanging of all so he has to somehow
react to it ok so now I know I can take
and have this this diagonal here opened
up the non-diagonal so let's go to the
floor
yeah this is a slightly important game
because if I win it and back to 2,400
it's really has been a while okay and oh
look a 3 maybe this is pointless or not
sure cannot cover it I Quincy one Roxy
three wins the queen or wins material
and if he moves one of the nights again
there's probably a five
hmm okay I can take it go Queen back
bring back crenate yeah precise analysis
is king um I don't don't see much better
at the moment so the d6 is hanging ok
I'll discover it
okay it's interesting can also go look a
one in this position I one dive d5 as a
movie okay I'll go for it I'm very
unsure but this thing is now i can take
on d3 here or take here and yeah i'm
like dead on the light squares this is
why I was hesitating and probably I
should have shouldn't have played this I
i really dislike it now that i have a
clearer view of it i am giving chances
to swindle here from proposition wear
black wasn't fantastic shape mmm damn it
ah very bad
check
now I should be okay even though time
learning of being okay it's just not
what what you want or what I wanted from
them from the start when I was just in
great shape
okay it would be cool to get can also
trade queens here of Queen d5 it drops a
pond oh ok let's do it for simplicity
check this is a draw objectively
speaking but still have to have to prove
it check check
okay this is a draw but he will win this
on time draw a third it's a drawing
position maybe you can out our tempe be
here something that that's called that's
possible maybe that's possible maybe yes
maybe yes yeah like what if that's all
done could could could be could be lost
cookie lost em this is the typical this
is the typical defensive set up here
maybe I'm too far down or back let's say
and possible i was aiming for that of
course i didn't need to allow it but i
was thinking okay this is this is the
clean draw i know i'm no no no I have to
do this of course I have to do this of
course I have to monito that porn that
was stupid I have to monitor all that
porn and wait until he moves it forward
and then Bishop piayed that is this this
is what makes the draw now is king is
some is forced to stay in near the pond
and that makes the draw okay I mean I
would have lost some time but yeah
what's the difference it was very stupid
because I had a great position here here
white is in not great shape but I should
just play normal moose probably this is
this is not bad okay Bishop g4 given by
the engine but it's yeah okay with
normal moose blood will always be
slightly better because of the
because of the bishop pal so here look
the eight now the computer agrees with
with everything up to here and now it
wants to play Bishop g4 yeah this is
probably better I mean it's better than
what I did this wasn't a great idea 122
yeah breakthrough on d3 but he gets all
this activity and that was very annoying
even though maybe this isn't all that
bad it made me go with 25 go to the
ending never the general idea was
terrible with d5 that gives the computer
smooth Queen to Bishop device is just
wrong bishop is in strong position there
it controlled c5 so that d5 can become a
much better option the engine wants to
do this now this oh sorry this is this
and Queen to see one it gets roughly
minus 10.9 now yeah okay black black is
in good shape of course he overlooked
this e for trick which is well known
that i stumbled into that one's on a
tournament game that was really shocking
my opponent flight that and you are you
on that square million times and still
they can play it yeah now this is this
is nice okay it was a tough game thanks
for watching